the two women who live with our Kelly
are defending him in their relationship
with him in the strongest terms 21 year
old Ezreal Clary and 23 year old
Joycelyn savage told us they love Kelly
while their families claim he has
brainwashed them in an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning the two
women told us there is nothing
inappropriate about their arrangement
with the 52 year old singer what is your
relationship both of you with with with
our Kelly we're with him that's what it
is and we're in a relationship with him
right a very strong relationship with
you yes most definitely
you know how do we say this without
being inappropriate is this a three-way
relationship or do each have a separate
relationship with them how does this
work curious individual relationships
with Hammond right we all are family all
together we have our moments where we
sit and watch movies off together we go
to amusement parks all together I'm not
talking about as well go into movies and
sit and watching going to parks I'm
talking about who's that is it a
three-way sexual relationship actually
well here to talk about my personal life
and I would never share with no one what
I do in or outside of the bedroom and as
a woman I'm sure you would not either no
I wouldn't but I okay then tell me no
question no you're right I would not but
this is a very different circumstance
it's not there's people all over the
world who have multiple girlfriends it's
no different do both of you all believe
you're in love with him yes absolutely
of course should your parents be
concerned no why
well my parents knew where I have always
been for four years they have known they
know that I've been well taken care of
they never thought you were missing as
well they just were wondering if you
were okay
well my parents have actually came to
Chicago and seen me a few times they've
I've talked to them they stopped
answering my calls you know what they
say they say that you were you were
brainwashed I talked to your dad last
night he says my daughter is brainwashed
and he's very concerned he said he was
here two days ago and you wouldn't even
look him in the eye okay I wouldn't look
him in the eye because he's a liar
he's a manipulative liar I'll tell you
why their concern as well because they
say she's 17
we found text messages that indicated
that she was having sex with our Kelly
when she was 17 is that true no that is
a lie that is a lie I was not having sex
with him at 17 why would they want to
lie about you their dog okay so when I
first met Robert my parents told me to
lie about my age so when I met him he
thought that I was 18 on top of that
when I was 17 my parents were actually
making me trying to get me to take
photos with him take sexual videos with
him all kinds of stuff wait wait wait
your parents encourage you to do sexual
videos with our Kelly yes and they said
because if they ever have to blackmail
him what they're trying to do now they
can use it against him which is exactly
what they're doing
Joycelyn I see you nodding a lot with
what she's saying why are you nodding in
agreement with what she's saying because
everything that she's saying is true
my parents are basically out here just
to give money and yours you're saying
the same thing well our parents both of
our parents are basically out here
trying to get money in scam because they
didn't agree on what happened
you know with music or wherever it could
be and they're just very upset this is
the first I'm hearing to be honest with
you that your parents are trying to get
money from art Kelly okay because your
father told a very different story
yeah to me last night yeah he's he's the
manipulative he's very manipulative so
he's the one you need to watch out for
but uh my dad and my mom they started to
send threats to both me and him they
said oh I'll call your nigut pictures
all over the world I'm going to ruin you
I'm going to ruin him if he doesn't send
$20,000 to this bank account by Monday
I'm gonna put everything out there and
then $10,000 after that you're trying to
solicit me like I'm some hole I'm not
I'm your child
exactly yeah you sound very angry with
your parents you sound very angry and
very pained
tell me I draw while you're crying tell
me because you want to be all because
that's the world we live in negative
these cells exactly Jocelyn and Ezreal
this is more than gossip this is more
than just rumors
these are decades of allegations against
Robert okay we're not here to talk about
decades we're here to talk about what
our parents are doing right now right
and what they're doing right now is all
for money right now both sets of parents
deny ever asking Kelly for money or
receiving money from him you know as I
watch that that as I was talking to them
because I had talked to the father there
are two very different stories I'm sure
mr. Clary if he watches this this
morning his head will explode because he
has a very different version of what
these young women are saying and his
team had told us that our Kelly would
not be in the room after the interview
started he was around the corner behind
them they couldn't see him but it points
it at points during the conversation he
would call very loudly like that so they
were aware that he was there he wanted
them to know that he tried to stop the
interview backstage a couple a couple of
times he lies who was taking those
amazing photos that you've seen is my
makeup artist who's also very good
photographers you also see our Kelly
came up to him and said should I stop
this interview should I stop this
interview he never did so the girls at
some point were certainly aware that he
was there and I want I just wanted to
say as a mother get your things let's go
you are 21 you are 23 and he is 52 years
old and I know many people believe age
is just a number when you're looking at
these young women they parent a parrot
rather a lot of what he is saying it's
it's ugly to watch but abuse is ugly and
the manipulation that continues and the
the powerlessness and trying to feel
powerful and the blame it's these are
it's a bad situation I think one day
years from now they will everybody will
look back on this and just say it's very
sad very tawdry and just very very I
hope that what comes of this is that
people go to the websites and we should
post them too
that his ex-wife talked about where you
can look at the signs of whether you're
in an abusive relationship or not
because you'll find out hey I'm an
eighth of these ten and then you realize
I need help yes now they do not think
they're being abused or manipulated or
brainwashed but again they're 21 and 23